good morning everybody
and welcome to this latest meeting of
the trafford cov19 public
engagement board going to thank you all
for your attendance today
i have apologies this morning from eli
caddick
kirsty johnson sarah radcliffe
councillor denise weston councillor
robert chilton councillor
akanola and helen grant and i'll just at
this point like to mention that
we removed community enforcement from
the agenda because
in light of the relaxation of
regulations there is nothing further
to enforce and at this point i'd just
like to put on record my thanks to helen
for the contributions she has made to
these meetings
um are there any further apologies
i don't see any thank you are there any
declarations of interest in any items on
today's agenda
no i don't see there um item three then
can i take the minutes of the last
meeting as read and as an accurate
record of that meeting
thank you um at this point i'm going to
just
switch the agenda and invite rebecca
demayne to come in to talk about max
vaccination because she does have to go
to a further meeting uh shortly so over
to you rebecca on mass vaccination
thank you very much chair um and thank
you for
switching the agenda around so um as
always i will start with the numbers
so um the vaccination doses continue to
um
increase despite as mentioned um last
time a slight slowing down in terms of
uptake but as of monday
we had delivered more than 163 000 first
doses
and more than 135 000 um second doses
uh so continue to see a great success in
terms of
uptake um still aware of um
some hard to reach groups and
populations in particular areas
within trafford which public health
colleagues might update further on
and looking at alternative um ways to
kind of
approach and provide messages and
actually provide some vaccination access
as well to some of those population
groups and
so that work continues working closely
with our community engagement team
um in terms of updates and so some of
you may be aware or heard that we did um
a pop-up clinic at old trafford cricket
ground on sunday
and took advantage of the um the
100 ball series which was at both the
women's and the men's
um matches on sunday this on the back of
a previous committee that i've been to
here and and one of you raised the
kind of energy and vibe that might be um
a way to kind of target young people at
a sports venue and pleased to say that
was a real success we actually
ran out of vaccine and had to go and get
more at one point so we did 176 um
vaccines both first and second doses
both pfizer
and astrazeneca and feedback very much
that this was
really convenient for people they could
be getting the vaccine whilst doing
other things
so the feedback we were getting
particularly from the younger population
was
not about hesitancy but about
convenience and that's something that as
i say we need to think about with some
of our other
harder to reach groups and make it more
convenient and
for them um so we are on the back of
that we are running another pop-up
clinic
today and so that will be from noon till
7 pm
and that is being held at the town hall
and and we are taking
advantage of the opportunity of a
further qriket um 100 ball series being
taking place at old trafford emirates
old trafford and also a manchester
united game tonight
as well versus brentford so this will be
walking
an opportunity for any people aged 18
plus to get their first or second dose
again pfizer and astrazeneca available
um and
and anybody else we've done some um
targeted work with local businesses and
residents as well of the old trafford
area so
um that will be going on later on today
so um some some good kind of different
ways to
deliver the program in terms of the
phase
three rollout which is the booster
program that i mentioned last time which
we're anticipating to go live from
september
we have had early indications that all
of our primary care networks will
wish to sign up to the um phase three
even those that didn't continue with
phase two because this is about again
the most vulnerable in our population
and also our community pharmacies have
all expressed an interest so we will
have
um really significant provision for both
the booster and that will
um coincide with the flu program as well
so that's good news
and then the only other thing i wanted
to update on some of you may have seen
that the
um the mandatory vaccination of
older people's care home staff the
legislation was
passed um and we have a grace period now
from the 22nd of july
to the 11th of november um to encourage
as many staff as possible
and with a time scale of when they would
need to have their first vaccine
in order to get their second vaccine in
time for that 11th of november deadline
so working very closely at the moment
with our local authority colleagues and
the homes
and to develop a plan both um in the
short term and in the long term because
we do realize that this will have an
impact
and so we'll bring further detail when
we have it and that was it for my update
today happy to take questions as always
thank you rebecca are there any
questions please for rebecca
uh councillor blackburn
uh thank you could could ask do we know
what percentage
of um 18 to 29 year olds
have had their first job and if we do
do we know sort of the sort of
percentage of
male female
we do have that information cancel that
but i've not got it to hand in front of
me at the moment
um so what i'll do is i'll i'll find the
latest data and make sure that that's
shared so i will i will get that
circulated apology i don't have that
right in front of me just now
thank you rebecca any further questions
at all from anybody
thank you for your contribution this
morning rebecca i'll let you get off
then to your next meeting
and we'll see you next time thank you
very much thanks everybody
bye-bye um right we'll just resume on to
the agenda then
folks um this is the update on the
current curving 19 situation in trafford
uh eleanor um it would appear our rates
are beginning to
fall is this a false dawn
over to you um i think at the moment we
don't know
it's it's really encouraging that the
rates are coming down
um but what we've also seen is a slight
drop in our testing
and our positivity is still very high so
there is a concern that with schools
closing
and obviously children secondary school
children and all of the teachers
were regularly undertaking lft tests and
if any of those were positive we're
going on for pcr testing
so with the closure of schools we'd
expect that although obviously those
people can continue to test
we suspect many of them may not be
continuing to test
so we are seeing a drop in our testing
rate
um and with the positivity rate
remaining very high and this is
and we've got quite a mixed picture
across greater manchester but in many
cases what we're seeing is the testing
rate decreased slightly but the number
of people who are tested
more a higher proportion of them testing
positive
so it's still quite it's i mean our
positivity rates are very high
still um uh so
at the moment i would say we would
not be confident that uh this is
this isn't that we're um well at the
moment we can't be confident that we are
still picking up all the cases we might
have done previously
obviously if people are symptomatic
we're more they're more likely to come
forward
our hospitalization rates are still
going up slightly
so the other thing that i think and
we've heard a lot about
it is the um the pandemic and how many
people are having to self-isolate
because of being ping now obviously
you're only pinged if you are a contact
of somebody so our case rates even
though they are coming down
are still very very high and because
most people
are going out more um we'd expect
more people to people to have more
contacts
and i think the thing i was wanting to
bring to the board's attention
is the difference between being
identified as a close contract through
track and trace where you legally have
to
self-isolate and being identified as a
contact through
a ping on the app what we're seeing what
we'd expect to see
as restrictions are raised is that we
would expect to see
people reporting more close contact
because they're doing more things so
when you're when you're
mainly um you know maybe going out to
work not doing anything else everything
else is shut
and you're only mixing with your family
it's not very surprising that the
contacts that people report
are their household members but as
things open up we'd expect
the contacts of a case to go up the
number of people that
people say they've been in in close
contact with we'd expect that to
increase
and we're not really seeing that
increase it's gone up very very slightly
over the last week
but most people are still reporting
under three contact direct
close contacts i other people who should
self-isolate
through test and trace and that is
worryingly low
so what we're concerned about at the
moment is we may not be getting all of
the close contacts coming forward
and it's the point of a test is to act
on the consequences and that means
self-isolate yourself
and also make sure that any of your
close contacts you could have given it
to
are also self-isolating so
if you're pinged the difficulty we have
with the ping on the app
is that it is quite difficult for people
to know whether that's how
when it happens exactly so you get the
day but you don't get more detail than
that
and thinking back to what you might have
been doing and so i would encourage
people
two things one is i would really
encourage people if they if they have
symptoms to make sure they go and have
that pcr test
also as soon as they go and have that
pcr test and if they've got symptoms
alert your friends that you might have
been in contact with and make sure
they're really aware of this
so that they can start self-isolating as
quickly as possible
while you're waiting for the results
particularly any household members
but also with your friends just let them
know so that they start to be a little
bit more cautious themselves
because what was what i'm really
concerned about at the moment
is that while we know that for many
people covet is not a serious disease
for many other people it is a very
serious disease and
um even and and we still have
large numbers of people who haven't been
vaccinated so the messages are
absolutely please go and get that
vaccination it gives good protection
about us
against hospitalization and and against
death
but you could still be transmitting the
disease you do need to be really aware
of it and we don't want
anyone getting long covered because that
really is a miserable thing for anyone
to have
and and do think about the contacts that
you might be having and the fact that
you
you could be that as we see more people
more people are likely to be at risk but
actually
with any infectious disease the people
you're most likely to give it to and the
post people you're most likely to catch
it from
are the people you're closest to so
please help us with that contact racing
so that we can stop
people passing con covered on to to
other people
um i think uh
we'll be talking um and i'm sure ben
will cover in his update
um what we're doing around the
exemptions um
obviously there are exemptions for some
double vaccinated people
what we're saying in that we've got a
process in place for people in the
direct
health and social care field but we are
saying that anybody who's a household
contact should not be
in the workplace even if they are double
vaccinated because the risk of them
going
and giving that giving kovitz who in a
care home for example
could be it could be massive if if we
take um covered into care homes
so we're really wanting to be very clear
with people that if you're a household
contact of someone
you know you don't want to be going back
home potentially catching it and then
taking the infection back into your
workplace
so we we are encouraging people to be
really really cautious about how they
use these exemptions
will and ben i think we'll be able to
talk a little bit more about what we're
doing about
um the additional testing offers
thank you elena are there any questions
at all from anyone for eleanor
i think again i would strongly encourage
people if you can work from home
please do keep working from home at the
moment because although the rates are
coming down
they're still over 415 per hundred
thousand which is you know nearly the
highest they've ever been
just because rates are coming down and
that is fantastic news they won't stay
down unless we help keep them stay down
so please please do work from home if
you can
maintain social distancing meet your
friends outdoors wherever possible
wear a face covering if indoors and um
do try
and be respectful of other people and
their need for space because
even if you're perfectly healthy not all
of your friends not all of your family
may be so
please do be very cautious um and
remember you know that actually i think
we've all got quite used to having a bit
of space around us
um it's quite nice um so please don't
don't go don't crowd into other people's
spaces particularly in places like
supermarkets
give people a little bit of distance
especially in venues where we with
places that we all need to use
and everybody should be feeling safe to
go to so places like supermarkets
you know do wear your face coverings and
do make sure that you give
other people plenty of space because
many people in
using a supermarket we need everybody to
feel safe going into places like
supermarkets
thank you and i've got questions lined
up from council accordingly and
councillor new brush i'll take council
accordingly first thank you
uh just a quick one um eleanor you
you talked about the um
increased activity following the air the
the the freedom day or whatever
in some ways i haven't seen that
increased activity i think it's still
quite quiet it will change with football
matches
and the cricket match today there are
isolated but
the shopping centers even the traffic
center was quite quiet
um the other day i i'm
i don't think we're there yet to know my
normal behavior
so there may be some more to go but i
don't know what
whether we've got any uh stats on that
on
trams or buses that would give us an
indication of whether
activity really is going back to normal
i think i think in some places it's i
think we're having a
what what's is ideal is to have a slow
return to normal
because you'd expect to see an increase
in cases when you lift restrictions
we obviously that we're just getting to
the point of getting the data through
from the 19th it's still a bit early
but i think to be honest we probably saw
a bit of the increase
because people started behaving
differently a little bit earlier
um particularly around the football and
everything you know a lot of a lot of
people are out and about a lot more
um with with all the excitement around
the euros and understandably
so so it may be that we started seeing
that increase a little bit earlier
and that actually that may have
encouraged people when the restrictions
lifted
and the numbers were starting to go up
whether that has encouraged people to
behave a little bit more
cautiously and what i would certainly
say is that
i think that's a good thing we should be
trying to lift our you know change our
behavior slowly
not all at once if we can slow it down a
bit
then that will lead to fewer people in
being infected overall especially as the
vaccination rate increases
so i think the fact that we're not quite
bad if it doesn't feel like we're back
up to completely normal yet
i think that's a very good thing and i
think the main thing is for me the main
thing is making sure that
um places that everyone should be able
to use whatever your health status
are feeling as safe as possible that is
a really important thing for me
because we do need people to feel safe
going out and about we do
need people to be able to go and do
their own shopping and those sorts of
things while feeling safe and that's
really important for people's physical
and mental health
um so i think i think if it if it does
feel like it's not too crowded that's
that's a great sign
and congratulations to everybody for
maintaining that because um
let's try and make it feel as safe as
possible so that we can get
the people who are anxious out and about
more and keep it safe for them
thank you and of course as a council we
lead by example because of our very
cautious
phased re-entry to the workplace for our
own staff
um councillor new grosh uh thank you
elena for the
presentation uh can i tease a bit more
information out of
i mean it's the drop in uh reported
covid cases
um can i ask what actually is our
positivity rate right now
um and the second question is
is is there a correlation between the
reduction in testing being done
and the is it a direct correlation in
reduction in
in positive tests
so um i've i'm just back from three days
leave so i'm going to um
ask about the on the testing it's um
we're not sure we are seeing a drop
particularly in our working age
population we're starting to see the
drop and then younger people
our positivity rate um as
of the i'm just looking at the data now
um until the 22nd of july
our positivity rate is 11.4 percent
which is a slight decrease on the
previous rate
um and we've had a decrease in testing
as well and
um so our testing rate is now roughly
the same
it's lower than the england average and
just slightly above the northwest
average but it's in the same ballpark as
those averages where
previously we've quite often had testing
rates very much higher than that
um our positivity rate was i think a
fortnight ago a week ago about 12.5
so it is coming down it's good but
that's still over 10
of the people going for a test to a
testing positive and that is you know
that is a significant number
um and where we're and we've
luckily for us we're starting to see a
drop in our over
60s rates but that drop is is
slightly less marked um yeah so we're we
are seeing a drop in all ages but our
over 60s rates to that week
is at 113 per hundred thousand which
again is higher than we would like
and i think there was a second part of
the question which i might have missed
i was okay is there a correlation
between the
drop in cases and the drop in
um testing i mean is it does it look
like we have the direct correlation
there
or or is it not a direct correlation i
think
we would i think to look at that in any
detail we probably want to go and look
to have some look at who which age
groups are testing more and less and so
on so we can bring a report back on that
to see whether where the drops in
testing are happening and whether
they're the same as the drops where
we're seeing the drops in the case rates
similarly by geography so i think we can
we can come back we one of the things
we'll be doing over this next week
is just doing a little bit more delving
into what's happening with the testing
and where are we seeing the positive
case rates
and are we see you know are we
suspecting
that we're missing cases and if so where
and why
so globally trafford situation some some
other areas have seen
a big bigger decrease in testing and a
bigger increase in their positivity
at the moment for trafford it's it's
looking relatively good
because we've seen that decrease in our
positivity alongside a decrease in
testing
but our positivity is still higher than
i would like it to be
thank you very much thank you elena um
councillor blackburn thank you
um within the next four weeks the
premier football season's
restarting i've got my season ticket for
city
ready and i'll be going we're gonna have
an influx of
people from out of the borough obviously
coming to
home matches at united and
obviously there'll be people from the
borough going to obviously
both to old trafford and to etsy had um
are we ready for rises
that are likely to happen you know due
to
um fans you know visiting the grounds
i think i mean certainly experience from
um family reports back from wembley from
people we know who went there seemed to
be quite a lot of cases linked to
to that trip to london whether that was
how much was caught in them at the
football and how much with the travel to
and fro and so on
my advice to everybody going into the
match and i'll look out for you at the
city grand and councillor blackburn um
is that um i would be extremely cautious
around the concourse areas try and spend
as little time as possible as you can
inside and i would strongly encourage
people to wear
face coverings in those indoor areas um
i think we we are working very closely
with manchester united obviously in
trafford to make sure that it's as safe
as possible
um and they are trying to put in as many
safeguards as they possibly can
but obviously with that increased mixing
um
you there is there is risk but i would i
think the risk is much more from
potentially the travel to and from the
matches the watching the matches and the
pubs we know from
from the euros experience that we
certainly saw
cases linked to people watching in
sports clubs and so on
so there will be increased risk from
um from from the attendance of the
matches there will be
increased risk because of general more
social gatherings around and about it
but we're working very closely to make
sure that those risks are minimized
um and as i say i think it from the
from the football point of view from
going to the stadium the biggest risk
will definitely be around the concourse
areas any crowded areas
so again do try you know i would
strongly encourage people to try and
make sure that they
um keep outside as well as much as
possible
and try not to congregate in the
concourses and and if you have any
additional vulnerabilities
i would very strongly recommend that
people try not to be in the concourse
areas for any length of time
helen i know helen has been working very
closely with united and the cricket club
on all of this
thank you are there any further
questions i think helen wanted to come
in
hello matt
helen are you on mute uh yeah what can
you hear me now
yes you can sorry i don't know what's
going on with my system this morning
so we've been working very closely with
the regulatory team and the safety
advisory group which advises man united
and the qriket around safety
um old trafford both teams have been
really open to working around making
sure everything is covered secure
there's lots of communication out going
out to spectators before the matches um
and during the matches as well and then
the other side
sorry excuse me is that kate in our
outbreak hub um has access to what is
known as
coincidence reports or common exposures
so we can
see when there's been a peak or you know
any kind of activity linked to a large
event and then we feed that back
to um the organizers so that we can work
again together to try to mitigate
against any increases
so there's a lot of kind of ongoing work
involved in the event management at the
moment
and again it does it does require people
to think
so when we do contact racing there's two
elements to it one is to find out
who who you might have been in touch
with and who could who you might have
given kovit to
and help them self-isolate but the other
part is
to think about where you might have got
it from and so it's really important
that people are as honest as possible
about where they've been so that we can
find out
if there are sites that are particularly
risky
because often there are mitigation and
procedures that we can put in place to
reduce those risks
but we need to be able to identify where
the risks are occurring so that we can
support it
so again i would just strongly urge
people to be as honest as they possibly
can
be with um with our contact tracers
because the more we
learn about where the where people are
getting infected the more we can
reduce the risks from those settings
that's not necessarily about closing the
setting or anything else
it is about reducing the risk and making
sure that um the
the settings are operating safely um so
please do be as honest as
as you know really ask people to be as
honest as they possibly can be
thank you elena are there any further
questions for eleanor at this stage
i don't see any so we'll move on to
uh the self-isolation uh pathfinder
update from kaiden before i ended
i did read in the manchester evening
news that actually trafford's one of the
best performing good
is the best performing borough in
ensuring people get
the self-isolation grant um i think
compared to other we compare very
favorably to the other nine authorities
but over to you kate
um chad i think helen's actually going
to update on the self-isolation and i'll
update and contact jason when she's
finished
thank you thanks kate can you i'm just
checking you can hear me with my
system playing up today yeah brilliant
thank you so kirsty's on leave today
um so she sent um a written update so
i'm just going to read it briefly to you
so it's she says we continue to follow
up all cases
where they have requested support when
contact traced by the national team
proactively contacting in m15 and m16
postcode areas
to identify any support needs overall we
managed to engage with 65
of the identified cohort with a
follow-up email sent to others who do
not answer the phone
uptake is low for support with just 12
requesting support
this is mainly around food provision and
follow-up support with the national
self-isolation support scheme which is
500 pounds
although uptake of support is low people
are grateful and appreciative of the
call
the 10 gm boroughs submit their date on
a weekly basis this information is
recorded on a master tracker
which is subsequently used by the
self-isolation pathfinder program board
and central government to review the
pilot
support provided today has included
supermarket vouchers
just to eat vouchers for very unwell
families which means that they have a
hot meal rather than having to cook a
meal
funded support stay in temporary
accommodation medicine delivery food
parcels and signposting to existing
services
over the remainder of the pathfinder so
it runs until mid-september
our local team plans to introduce a text
messaging service to reach people and
for them to respond
be able to supply emergency food
vouchers immediately
and identify what other support needs
people may have
that don't sit under the existing
national and welfare schemes
so that's the update from kirsty thank
you
thank you helen uh anyone any questions
on that at all
i don't see any so we'll move swiftly on
them to mass testing ben
thanks chair so a few things to go
through today to update you
um in the world of testing so first of
all there are
two new types of lateral flow tests so i
know all of you were very aware of the
the noble ones but now you've got two
more new ones to get your head around
um the first one is called the orange
gene test this will be for schools
it's nasal only it differs slightly in
the way that you process it although not
by much
and only takes 50 minutes to get a
result rather than 30 minutes which is
obviously really positive to cut that
time in half
um the second type of electro flow test
is
made by a company called acorn it's
called flowflex we're expecting that
sometime next month and that will be for
everyone else
essentially so again that will be a dual
nasal swab
and it will differ slightly the way it's
used although we haven't been given
details on that yet
so when we do have more information we
will let you know
my next update is around workplace
testing so
business this is business has been given
tests by the national team to provide
on-site testing
which has now largely come to an end
apart from critical workplaces which
i'll get to in my next bit of the update
but in trafford we have offered any
businesses
um that weren't able to access tests
with the national team
test ourselves we've had a number of
businesses take that up which is really
positive that they're going to continue
to do so
um so my next update is around
exemptions which eleanor um alluded to
before
so i think there's two things to talk
about here first of all
this is exemptions for close contacts of
frontline emergency services this was
the announcement that came on the 19th
of july um for for kind of key people
working in health and social care
and there's a number of different bits
of criteria that need to be filled
for these close contacts to be able to
be exempt from self-isolation
so number one you need to be fully
vaccinated um
number two you need to not be a home
contact as in
if you someone test positive you live
with you still need to sell isolate
number three you will need to have a
negative pcr test first
number four um that particular
organization needs to complete a risk
assessment
um and you need to be deemed critical to
the business
and finally you will still need to go
and undertake daily electrical flow
tests
so there are a number of different hoops
that need to be jumped through for this
so in trafford we're asking that risk
assessment i spoke of before
it's going to be sent to public health
so we can review that and
make sure that that organization has
followed all those processes
so that's kind of far as i say frontline
health and social care
um also um from last saturday there was
the announcement that exemptions would
also be
applied to other critical workplaces so
the police fire services transport
racism etc
um we know they're doing this in three
cohorts first of all anyone that already
had
on-site testing and we're doing that on
a regular basis
second anyone that had signed up to
workplace testing but hadn't actually
started it yet
and then finally anyone that hasn't
signed up at all um so we know initially
the first kind of cohorts were mainly
just supermarkets
um essentially how it works is if anyone
is interested they've got to go and
demonstrate they feel
that a they're within that set in the
first place and b and they have business
critical staff
that cannot be replaced otherwise um are
sent
on to the relevant department in the
government and then they need to get a
letter back with those named
um workers on that letter otherwise they
wouldn't be allowed to do so
and it's probably worth remembering here
that all of this comes to an end
on the 16th of august
um so other key messages then i think
it's just worth highlighting now that
there's been a new national campaign
launched this week
to remind the public of information
about continuing healthy behaviors
um to reduce that spread of covad um
second on the list
is testing and the two key elements
they're pushing are the ones we spoke
about many times before
of a regular twice weekly testing and b
take a pcr test even if you only have
mild
symptoms so that's my key updates this
week
on testing thank you ben are there any
questions at all for ben
councillor blackburn thank you
could ask please and have amy take not
the
workplace testing offer and if so do we
know
what the take-up has been
so they would have been able to go and
take it up in the so
as they went for those three different
cohorts so amy don't
currently have um on-site testing
at um at their warehouse so they
wouldn't have been able to take it up in
the in the first cohort so they may be
considering it for cohort three
which even then would only kind of give
them a guess um an additional
week two weeks before that um 16th of
august change that comes in place anyway
and obviously from that point onwards
um that's anyone who is a close contact
can go and have
a negative pcr and then not need to
self-isolate
so um i've not heard whether or not amy
are looking into it
to be part of that third cohort but they
wouldn't be able to sign up initially
anyway
um chairman could have just asked please
because there seems to be
a high rate of
that their employees having to to
isolate which
is having a knock-on effect on the bin
rounds
is is there anything that we can we can
do
in order to ensure that you know these
these rates lessen israel you know as as
as sort of basically that their ultimate
employer
well what i would say to you on that
council blackburn is that they're a
contractor
and and they have a responsibility to us
under that contract if they don't
fulfill it
uh there are penalties um and the matter
of testing is a matter for amy not a
matter for the council
okay all right thank you
are there any only further questions at
all for ben
although i do understand council
blackburn you can certainly share it
but it's uh i would say to you it's out
of the council's hands in terms of
how they particularly deal with their
actual employees on this matter
uh i don't see any further questions so
can we therefore move on to
contact tracing and outbreak management
and i'll bring kate in i've got it right
this time have a gate
you certainly have chair thank you and
just a brief update from
us um with respect to level two contact
tracing
which is our locally based offer that
service with our case rates um as you
would expect remains very busy
and in the last week we received 160
referrals for our contact traces to
follow up locally
these are cases that the national team
have failed to to make contact with
so they're always going to be more
challenging for us to reach but on
average we're reaching between 40 and 50
of those cases and so that's quite
significant when you're looking at the
numbers
um schools in early years have remained
fairly busy
and dropped off a little bit this week
with the schools closing
as um as you'll know the contact chasing
for schools is now passed over to the
national
test and trace service that passed over
on the 19th
however we have um continued our support
and we plan to continue our support to
our
our local schools and early earlier
settings because
they have valued highly the the local
support that they've been able to
receive over the last 12 to 18 months
we continue to proactively engage with
our business settings who are
experiencing a number of cases
we've supported three settings this week
with
outbreak control team meetings where
they've had more than five cases in a
a two week period um and we're moving
forward
um in line with what we were talking
about helen was talking about with
coincidence reports
we reviewed the reports on a daily basis
of
the settings where a number of positive
cases
have cited that they've been through the
contact tracing
and what we would plan to do over the
coming weeks
is to start to engage with the settings
where we're seeing
high footfall of positive cases where
people have been
and then subsequently tested positive
this sort of mirrors the activity that
we've been carrying out with the traffic
centers so we've been working very
closely with the trafford center
and all of the business settings within
the trafford center
um with early intervention support
around their their culvert security
and measures in the aim to hopefully
prevent any outbreaks linked to settings
and i think that sort of sums up the
activity where we're at at the moment
with contact chasing an outbreak
management
thank you kate are there any questions
at all for kate
kate i don't see any at all last chance
no questions
right that been the case can we
therefore move on to community
engagement and i'll invite to nigel to
speak to nigel smith thank you
councillor freeman so uh the the key
update updates i wanted to give today
first of all uh is on our uh
our summit engagement program so the
community engagement team are
in the final preparations for this
summer program
so we're going to be starting from next
week we're going to be in each of the
neighborhoods
uh working in each neighborhood for one
week on monday wednesday and friday so
next week we're going to be starting in
the central area on the second that's
the 2nd of august then from the 9th of
august in west 16th of august north
and the 23rd of august south so the aim
of the program
is to um to deliver key messages which
have been sent by eleanor and the public
health team
and what we want to do is to not only
keep the conversation going about covid
about helping to reduce the spread of
infections
promoting vaccination take up but also
around promoting those key public health
messages about being
healthy active staying safe and staying
well
to you know hopefully prevent kobe as we
head into the autumn
so the team are going to be joined by
volunteers linking in with partners
community groups
to ensure we can get our messages out to
reach as many people as possible
activities in parks library shopping
centers things such as that
and where we can linking them with
existing projects activities
so as to kind of maximize that football
and widen our reach into the community
um we're going to also have a
questionnaire where we can get some
insight from people
um i'm gonna have giveaways freebies and
kind of make it a kind of fun
interactive thing
with activities for people to do as well
so that's a big thing that we could be
focused on over the next
uh four weeks in terms of some activity
that's going on
at the moment um today the team are
going to be visiting the bread and
butter thing
uh delivery at san francisco more later
today
to engage with local residents around
positive covert messages and also
getting some insight into how the
community are feeling about the lifting
of
restrictions and we are doing that in
partnership with the sale more community
partnership
and another key thing that we're working
on is um
we're working with the public health
team and piloting a really detailed
evidence-based questionnaire which has
been adapted to the covid programme
so what we're really trying to
understand and this is what rebecca
mentioned before is try to understand
better the reasons why some people have
not yet had the vaccine
so um the pilots taking place this week
and last week in the north of the
borough in those areas where we've seen
uh lower vaccine take up so we did some
phone calls
last week with people and this week
we're having some conversations with
some residents on the doorstep
so the initial pilot is going to be
involved speaking to around 40 to 50
people to get some initial insight but
also
to get some feedback on the
questionnaire itself and then once we've
completed that
test phase i had a bit of time to
evaluate and fine-tune the questionnaire
we'll then be rolling it out
wider for a wider survey later in the
summer so this is all about us trying to
get some feedback
from residents through the questionnaire
which will give us a better
understanding
about how to provide information
vaccination services more effectively
but also to help shape our
community engagement and connectivity
going forwards
so those the main updates i wanted to
give a final thing i just wanted to
mention was just around the clinic
so the engagement team and comms teams
are continuing to promote the clinics
uh including the walking clinics where
no appointment is necessary and
i just really wanted to mention the key
role which
about the volunteers are continuing to
play in the vital
role in supporting clinics uh including
the
clinic or the cricket club on sunday and
we're really pleased to now have our
volunteering officer
in post who's claire mcguire who's doing
an excellent job in
coordinating the volunteers where
they're required and claire is currently
streamlining that process as well so he
gets a
you know a proper filled in request form
from the clinics
or the other plans activities to make
sure we know exactly what the role is
required and any special requests but
uh that works going really well uh that
was the update
from me today thank you thanks nigel can
you
let us know what the uh uptake's been on
community champions
sorry could you say again sorry council
freedom could you just let us know what
the uptake has been in regards to
community champions
so for communities champion so far we've
had um i think it's
around 30 to 35 committee champions that
so far signed up
so uh what what those those numbers
we've had so far
have been primarily people that we've
contacted through kind of social media
and getting the coms out and kind of
like new
new people if you like the majority of
those which is really positive and what
we're really trying to focus on now is
trying to capture
those people because there's lots of
people that are that are
really acting as community champions
already so what we want to do is try and
get those people now signed off as
champions to try and almost double that
number
and try and widen the spread of
committees champions that we have but
that's where we are at the moment but
yeah
certainly we really want to uh recruit
as many champions as we can and if
people are seeing this and are
interested in signing up to be a
community champion
if they can go to the council's website
and there's the details there on how to
sign up
thank you i've got a question from
council accordingly
thanks chair it's just a quick one uh
over dropping centers um
making sure we do get lots of publicity
out
when we're doing them um
i mean i i try and publicize as much as
i can
and then i i can't help noticing it it's
mainly
timperley and ernst and partington and
the old trafford ones have
not really been coming through so
i've not seen huge amounts of council
publicity about them
um so it's really about making sure we
get these going in the north really
and uh when we do get them going
publicizing them
as much we because i think that i i
think personally
my instinct says there's a lot of scope
for the
uh dropping centers making it convenient
then
they're the most effective thing uh that
we've got
so the more we can publicize them the
better
but the other thing uh slightly attached
to that you might be able to reassure me
quick it's not a lack of volunteers
isn't it in the north
um that's preventing this
sorry mike nigel yes
certainly that is that there's not an
issue with lack of volunteers i
know that the the clinics in the north
that we've been supporting that we've
had really excellent support from
volunteers
uh and uh unfortunately ellie's not on
the call today but she
should have been here she'd be able to
be able to explain all the kind of
uh publicity and social media comms that
has been put out in terms of promoting
the clinics but i know
a lot of activity has taken place
throughout the clinics not just through
the council comms but also through
the different networks and connections
that we have with different community
groups
um to make sure and through the hubs you
know for the networks that they've got
to promote the clinics but can certainly
take that back to le
in terms of that comment from council
accordingly to see if there's any more
that we can do around promoting those
north clinics
thank you for that and thanks
councilwoman can i just say check i
encourage all of us that are on twitter
or facebook
to actually look out for the trapper
council messages around this
and take the opportunity to retweet and
repost
as and when to come i do that on a
regular basis
and i'd encourage others to do that as
well it's about getting the message out
are there any further questions at all
for for nigel
thank you for your update nigel um
is there any other business at all from
anybody
i don't i don't see it either so in
drawing the meeting to a close guy thank
you all again for your attendance
clearly
we've still got a long way to go but
uh progress it would appear is being
made thank you for all
to all of our public health teams
environmental health teams
um without you and the community contact
teams as well without you we wouldn't be
where we are thank you very much indeed
everybody have a good day okay bye-bye
now